cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us right now to
discuss that and also the fed's latest
rate hike and what that means for
everybody at home jill good morning how
are you doing doing well all right so
this is the fourth time the federal
reserve has acted this year um should we
expect more increases so absolutely
we've got three more meetings through
the end of the year and at each of those
meetings we expect more rate hikes fed
chair powell said so in his press
conference right now rates are at two
and a quarter to two and a half percent
these short-term rates i would suspect
by the end of the year we're at three
and a half percent so we don't know the
size we don't know the timing but there
will be more hikes okay so should we see
any relief
could we see any relief soon with the
raising prices well i think that we are
actually going to see relief just in the
next report already oil prices are down
we're at over 120 and now we're at 95 to
100 gas prices down 70 cents a gallon
since the peak early reports right now
some food prices coming down coffee
avocados cooking oil that could really
show some relief in the coming months
but we'll still be at high prices how
would these higher rates impact people
looking to borrow money this is rough
yeah sure if you've got a short-term
loan like a credit card balance an auto
loan maybe it's a small business loan an
adjustable rate mortgage that's going to
cost more money but when it comes to
longer rates those are determined by the
market so when we look at mortgage rates
mortgage rates have nearly doubled from
a year ago but that's actually because
the market expects higher rates overall
you mentioned federal reserve chair
powell in yesterday's meeting he
actually said we're not in a recession
um but you know we're looking at this
and we're hearing about recession it's
almost like a buzzword now um are we
well i mean look we don't know because
the way we determine recessions is this
place called the national bureau of
economic research has something called
the dating committee they look at a lot
of factors and they say after the fact
here's when a recession began here's
where it ended here's what powell's
really worried about he's saying
everyone's talking about recession it's
getting ingrained people are worried
about inflation we don't want it to
become a self-fulfilling prophecy and
he's saying that it's sort of hard to
square that we're in a recession if the
labor market is still pretty solid we've
had 2.7 million jobs since the beginning
of the year unemployment rate is at 3.6
at the end of the day it doesn't really
matter because i'll tell you what it's a
scary word though it is but i want to be
clear the economy is slowing down that
is what the fed is trying to do the real
tricky part is are they going to slow it
down too much that we actually contract
or not and even if we contract if you
have a job you're going to feel good and
if you don't have a job even if we're
not in a recession you're going to feel
bad those are the two numbers i care
about job no job keeping it real with
jill schlesinger thank you thank you